we are here to document the lives of
people living in alaska
the harsh reality is the environment
we're up against it makes it tough to do
our job get out of there working on life
below zero can be very dangerous
guns here cameras here never know what
to expect
see that gonna be tough but we're gonna
get the shot
every scenario we got to prepare for
this well we're still smiling we're
having fun
still making life below zero yes
bring it on
it's 9 00 a.m day five of our
extended stay here at chandelar
i'm still waiting for a weather window
to get a plane in here
this beautiful blue sky here but the
area in between here and where we need
to get to is the problem
we're wrapped but uh here we remain it's
13 days without plumbing or
or heat every day i've thought including
today i thought there was a really good
chance we would get out
messaging back and forth via satellite
to uh
to the office and you know they're doing
our best their best to keep us safe so i
appreciate that and we just gotta wait
until things are safe to get out
what can you do man makes plans and god
laughs
so this is our gear pile staged on the
beach ready to go
if we get the call that the plane is
coming in we're just going to leave this
out unless the weather gets really bad
run pretty low on food it's definitely
getting to the point where
uh we're scraping by some peanut butter
this could come in handy
a couple of cans of sardines that's
about it
probably had about two or three days of
food left
we moved into glenn's sod house it's got
an open door and then a hole in the roof
dragged our tarp over here to kind of
close up the roof hole a little bit to
keep a bit more of the heat in we'd set
up cots
but just barely fit in the open space in
there and it's been pretty great little
home
so here's our door uh
keep the heat in at night it takes a
little bit of gymnastics
uh to get out in the middle of the night
without making a lot of noise and waking
up your mates
but it keeps the heat in really well
we need some wood to keep our sod house
warm we don't want to burn all of
glenn's wood
so we're going to go out into the forest
and get some
it'll keep us warm later and it'll warm
us up right now and give us something to
do
well you want a standing dead tree so
you're looking for
one that doesn't have any uh green
needles on it
doesn't seem like it's green at all
seems like it's dead
we could try for that one i think we
could take that down i think it'd be fun
guys a human beaver
starting to have a little concern about
it falling the other way
we'll see what happens yeah i think it
wants to go the other way
it's almost ready to go tony
[Music]
get out of there
yeah we got firewood
so now that we've dropped this tree on
the ground we need to cut it up
into manageable pieces we're about a
quarter mile
from the sod house right here so we're
gonna have to just carry them on our
shoulders we don't want to cut them too
big
we don't want to cut them too small
because that means more cuts and more
trips
so we'll just take a guess at what the
right length is and
uh cut it up into some chunks
[Music]
warm you up for sure you know what they
say tony wood warms you twice
we've got the tree cut up into four
usable chunks
that i think we can manage to carry out
of here on our own
so we'll do true trips we'll throw them
up on our shoulders
walk them out
[Music]
[Applause]
good job that was fun yeah it was thank
you
all right should do us a while
thanks for getting all that wood notch
yeah that was a fun project
yeah good group
[Music]
it's effort colder every night and
having all this wood is a
it's a killer thing to do i mean not
only is it like
it's keeping us warm in here for one
thing for sure but just having something
to do
is trapped in this sort of weird limbo
that we're in
uh you know waiting waiting waiting for
a new message from production a new
message from our friends or family
and just trying to find something to do
in the meantime to fill time
one of my favorite things about spending
an extended period of time
out in the backcountry is it really
gives you an appreciation for all the
things that we can kind of take for
granted
food is a huge part of that for the crew
i am very
very excited it smells amazing
[Music]
you